badger pour rentrer dans son lycée fait
désormais partie du quotidien des élèves
et des professeurs au lycée descartes de
tours ce système est en place depuis la
rentrée 2015 et a déjà fait ses preuves
l'établissement compte 1700 élèves ça ne
veut pas dire que le risque zéro
n'existe pas vous avez vu les élèves
entrés avec leur carte on peut avoir
effectivement des élèves qui déjeunent
qui s'infiltrent avec les jeunes par
contre le fait d'avoir badgés dans un
lieu enclavés comme le nôtre et dans un
centre ville où il ya beaucoup de
passage malgré tout a permis de réduire
les intrusions dans les amis son
intrusion qui sont pas toutes violentes
qui sont pas toutes vos affaires un
public quand même le d'adolescents et et
pour partie d'établissement mais on a
quand même beaucoup réduit autre
dispositif mis en place il ya un nom des
caméras installées dans les couloirs et
à l'entrée de l'établissement qui scanne
toutes les allées et venues enfin des
grilles de protection qui s'était avérée
efficace lors des manifestations contre
la loi travail au début c'était des
grilles destinés à prévenir le vol dans
la nuit mais elles nous étaient
commandés sur place maintenant elles
peuvent être commandés de l'accueil
autrement dit à tout moment s'il ya un
danger ont peu baissé les grilles et
confiné l'établissement autre
établissement autre exemple à grand
monde ici en fonction de l'entrée les
modes de contrôle sont différents
carte de cantine portail ou plus
récemment tourniquet mais pas de quoi
inquiéter les élèves
on sait bien dans un sens c'est bof dans
l'autre parce que bas dans un sens aux
usa sécurisé mais là bas y'a pas besoin
de carte c'était juste appuyé sur un
bouton quoi même si le mec rentrer par
là il ressort par là comme au début en
seconde ont passé tous par le portail
principal et depuis on passe pas plus
tôt par l'accueil
vérification de cartes de carnets pour
vérifier si on est vraiment du lycée eux
je trouve ça plutôt rassurant et c'est
pas non plus oppressant c'est normal la
question de la sécurisation des lycées
compétences de la région reste un
dossier complexe avec des mesures
spécifiques pour chaque établissement
cette année l'enveloppé régionale sera
de 700 mille euros des moyens qui ont
été fléchés ont été estimés en lien avec
l'établissement avec une absence de
chemin général c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas une bonne forme à appliquer pour
sécuriser un établissement scolaire à
l'essai mais une analyse au cas par cas
de la vulnérabilité du 17 et selon qu'on
a un lycée qui est très enclavée en
centre-ville au contraire un lycée
agricole avec beaucoup de surface en
pleine campagne
on n'a pas les mêmes configurations et
pas les mêmes réponses donc aujourd'hui
les crédits sion qui ont été estimés à
correspondre aux besoins et à cette
analyse que nous avons fait surveiller
sur la lys est du territoire en centre
val de loire on compte une centaine de
lycées publics et pour renforcer leur
sécurité
la région s'est engagée à investir 5,5
millions d'euros dans les prochaines
années